هذا الموضوع انضم الينا الان من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويريا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي يرحب بك معنا اذا هذا
التعليق الاخير الذي يقول فيه ان الروس
عرضه اليوم للضربات حتى في قلب العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو
نعم
تشهد الايام الاخيره تسعيد واضح جدا في
استخدام الطائرات المسيره على الاقل من
الجانب الاوكراني لجمله اسباب تاثير
العسكري محدود جدا
ومعظمها استنادا الى الجانب الروسي يتم
اسقاطه اما بالمضادات او من خلال التقنيات
الكمبيوتريه والتعمليات التشويش ولكن
بدات تلقي بظلالها في ابعاد اخرى كما اشار
المتحدث الاوكراني في البعد النفسي البعد
السياسي البعد الاجتماعي لانه هذا
التاثيرات وان لم تكن انيه لكنها تاثيرات
تراكميه روسيا تقول توصف ما يجري بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه التي كانت في البدايه
مؤطره زمان ومكانا ضمن اهداف سياسيه لكن
الجانب الاوكراني يع ان هناك حاله حرب
وبما انه حاله حرب اذا على الجانب
الاوكراني وهنا تحدث عن منطوق الجانب
الاوكراني يجب ان يستخدم كافه الوسائل
المتاحه له للتاثير في الابعاد العسكريه
والامنيه والسياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه هنا يبرز استخدام الطائرات
المسيره
لمجموعه اسباب كذلك اهمها رخيصه تصل الى
مدايات بعيده تصل الى قاعده انجلز وتصل
الى فوق الكرملين
احتماليه نجاحها تبقى قائمه رقم الحديث عن
عمليات الاسقاط لاعداد كبيره جدا امكانيه
اطلاقها من مناطق متعدده
وباتجاهات ومسارات مختلفه وبالتالي هذا
الامور جميعها تجعل من السهل استخدامها في
ظل التحديدات المفروضه من الغرب على
استخدام الصواريخ بعيده المدى
250 كيلو متر فاعلى طيب هذا التصعيد الان
في استخدام المساجرات ان كان في اتجاه
موسكو او القرم ايضا في الوقت الذي يفترض
ان يكون الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد قد بدا
يحقق نتائج الا يمكن ان نفهم هذه العمليات
على انها صرف نظر او تعويض
للهجوم الذي يصفه البعض بانه متعثر
لا يعني الامور متداخله ولا نستطيع ان في
الفصل بين كافه مظاهر العمليات العسكريه
بالامس كان هناك تصريح لاحد القاده
الاوكرانيين يتحدث عن قرب دخول القرن
وبالتالي هذا تصريح ان كان دقيقا ويعكس
الواقع الميداني وانا اضع علامه استفهام
وقط احمر اقول ان هناك مفاجات كبيره جدا
وتعيدنا الى التصريحات الغربيه ان الجهد
الرئيسي او الجراند ارمي الاحتياطي
الاستراتيجي لم يتم الزج به في المعركه
الان القرن تختلف عن داخل روسيا من وجهه
نظر القانون الدولي ومن وجهه النظر
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي هذه ارض اوكرانيه نعم
اعطيت في بدايه خمسينات القرن الماضي من
قبل الزعيم خريشوف ولكنها بحكم القانون
الدولي اراضي فمهاجمتها لا يختلف عن
مهاجمه او
باك موت او ما شابه ذلك اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه كنت
معنا من عمان شكرا